vice president kamala harris has been
criticized for opposing voter id
laws because she says rural people
cannot get photocopies
of their id cards in some people's mind
that means well you're going to have to
um
xerox or or photocopy your idea to send
it in to prove
you are who you are well there are a
whole lot of people especially people
who live in rural communities who don't
there's no
kinkos there's no officemax near them
last month president biden selected
harris to lead the administration's
effort to expand
access to the ballot box former
president donald trump
easily won the straw poll at the
conservative political action conference
this weekend
in texas the former president capturing
70 percent of the ballots cast
and firing up the crowd there with the
help of everyone here today we will
defeat the radical left the socialist
marxist and the critical race theorists
we will secure our borders we will stop
left-wing
cancel culture we will restore free
speech and fair elections
and we will make america great
again florida republican governor ron
desantis came in second in that straw
poll
at 21 let's bring in senior political
analyst britt
hume good evening brit i want to talk to
you about uh the former president and
where he stands as far as the power
in this party not just perhaps at cpac
but within the republican party
well brett i think he's going to be with
us a while longer maybe a
good while longer the strength in that
straw poll there now that's the most
conservative elements of the party
it isn't necessarily the sentiments of
the entire party but
there are not many republican
politicians today who want to speak out
against donald trump not because
they think that he should lead their
ticket in 2024
or that he could or that they can win
with him but because they believe that
his following is still sufficiently
strong in the party that they dare not
oppose him publicly
that is i think where he now stands when
he said in that speech you heard
that we just heard the last some of the
last uh phrases from that speech you
talked about we're going to do this
we're going to do that
it's not entirely clear if by we he
means the party and
him at the head of it or if he just
means the party i think an awful lot of
things are going to happen between now
and 2024 which will determine whether
he's in
in any shape to run or not but he's
still there and he's still
at the center of things and he's going
to make news and
get and and have attention wherever he
goes that's the fact
of life for republicans right and you
mentioned that speech let's take another
little piece of that uh this is again
the former president at cpac
i was banned by sleazebags i was banned
by bad people
they're far worse i don't say i'm
perfect but they're far worse than i am
i will tell you
they are far worse in other words the
entire system was rigged against the
american people and rigged against
a fair decent and honest election
but i've talked to a lot of republicans
who absolutely love
trump policies they love them but they
had a problem with
donald trump the man they also had as
far as what he did with twitter and how
he talked about things
but also donald trump on january 6th in
the wake of that
as he talks more and more about the
stolen election
how big a problem is that for
republicans as a party
i think it's a very big problem brett i
mean i think that i saw one poll not
long ago that reflects what you're just
talking about in which it was
people and the majority republicans said
they would like to win with his policies
a smaller number said they'd like to win
with him leading the way
and i think that's basically where the
matter now stands i think
a lot of rank and file republican
politicians and a lot of rank-and-file
republican voters wouldn't mind a bid if
he went away
uh they could then pick up his agenda
and run on it
the biden administration to date seems
to have left some plenty of
opportunities the president
the former president outlined a lot of
them in his speech on all kinds of
issues crime immigration
and so on down the list and so i think
the party feels it could be in a strong
position
um they're afraid to buck him but they
were they're afraid he'll lead him to a
defeat which is what they feared the
first time
uh and then he did lead them to defeat
the second time so
that's i think where they are um
and but he is it shows no signs of going
away
um we'll see what happens if you know he
gets indicted or something like that
that that might change the calculus
or he needs to spend his time uh keeping
his businesses together we'll see about
that as well
quickly that you mentioned the
administration they seem to be giving
republicans some low-hanging fruit with
the border
crisis there's some questions about the
economy obviously and about crime across
the country but vice president harris
you just heard that
talking about rural voters not being
able to get a photocopy of their id
they're now 70 plus percent of americans
who say
photo id id for voting is okay by them
this is a tricky issue for the democrats
they're trying to make the most of it
they're trying to label republicans as
people who want to suppress the vote
but a number of the things that the
republicans want to do in the laws they
are passing across the country and so on
are things that are popular and voter id
is very high on that list brett as you
suggest
i think it's a politically really stupid
to come out and criticize voter id
and i think you know there are obviously
people in the biden white house who kind
of wonder whether having kamala harris
out front on a lot of these issues
has turned out to be a very good move
she seems at times lighter than air
brett as always thank you